hey youtubers it's Charlie thank you
everybody that submitted questions on
the d23 videos this weekend there's a
whole lot of Captain America that really
stole the show a lot of Star Wars a lot
of Doctor Strange well a little bit of
Doctor Strange so I'm doing this a
little bit differently I'm just gonna
like pull questions in real time off of
the comments thread so let's get going
first question comic boy 67 asks I want
to see Baron Zemo wear the purple mask
just like in the comics they might do a
mask but for the most part the closest
that we get is say like crossbones
wearing that face mask like the
practical face mask so it's not quite
like it is in the comics but at least
spiritually it's halfway there
Daniel Bruhl is just one of those guys
that looks like a movie star so I don't
think they're gonna try and hide his
face too much but they might go the
crossbones route where he gets scarred
at the end of the film and then he has
to start wearing a mask next question
brave Katniss asks I heard a rumors that
the trailer for Civil War could be
released tonight sometime well no
obviously there was a version of the
trailer that leaked that got taken down
that's pretty standard fair that happens
for all the big trailers that they don't
release right away the best theory is is
that they'll either release one on its
own sometime at the end of October or
November or they'll release it with Star
Wars Episode seven typically they're
attached to like big movie releases and
an ant-man was just like a little too
soon the next two big movies that Disney
has before Star Wars Episode seven or
the Tom Hanks spy thriller and that that
doesn't really feel like a Disney Marvel
type movie and then there's the good
dinosaur they could use but that also
feels a little bit weird attached like a
big action movie trailer to this kids
Pixar animated film so I'm kind of
thinking that it's gonna be episode
seven before we see you like the full
blown trailer and it'll be way more than
the footage they showed off at d23 so if
you did watch that leaked trailer it'll
be way cooler than that next question
9la asks I saw a man yesterday stayed
for the post-credits scene well I
thought I did anyway now I find out
there's an additional one after the
credits and I feel like I'm missing out
okay so the post credits scene that you
missed is just the wasp costume Hank Pym
and Janet Van Dyne were making a new
suit when she died
Hank Pym just locked it away and at the
end of the movie he gives it to hope
Evangeline Lilly said that they did fit
her for a special wasp costume and Kevin
Feige was going to introduce her during
Captain America Civil War
but then Evangeline Lilly got pregnant
so she's like yeah I'm not gonna fit in
that suit anymore and Kevin Feige kind
of changed his mind and said you know
what we don't want to introduce her in
like a small role we want to do it in a
big way so we'll wait for a better
opportunity so hopefully we'll see
ant-man tube before infinity war they
might add it into the schedule even
though it's not on there right now if it
doesn't come then we'll probably see her
during infinity war maybe in one of the
other films like Captain Marvel it's
hard to say between now and the end of
phase 3 there's a mixture of space based
movies in a mixture of earth-based
movies so obviously the wasp is gonna
have to appear in one of those
earth-based movies next question Jakob
sailor asks what's more important peace
or freedom vote team Captain America I'm
guessing you're saying vote for freedom
if you're reading secret Wars right now
and all the tions there's actually a
Civil War tie-in comic that deals with
this issue like what would happen if the
United States was divided into I don't
want to spoil that storyline you can
read it if you want but it just it
posits the theory what if Civil War
never ended what if it just continued
indefinitely
next question abstract ask when is
Doctor Strange coming out that's gonna
be November like the beginning of
November next year not not this November
but the year after next question
Riverside asks they have to release the
trailer ASAP if they want to compete
with Batman V Superman it must have
spider-man in it too well I don't think
that they really care about Batman vs
Superman I mean both films are gonna
make a dumptruck of money it's gonna be
ridiculous I'll be really interested to
see though if that man V Superman makes
more money than Captain America Civil
War now they're not being released like
right next to each other so they're not
gonna compete directly Batman vs
Superman is out March 25th Captain
America Civil War isn't out til May 6 so
there's like a couple months in-between
those movies don't be surprised though
if Batman V Superman is still in
theaters I think they left Avengers like
the original Avengers film in theaters
for at least like 6 months almost
usually after the first month or two of
release though like a bunch of theaters
will drop it so they if it debuts in
like three or four thousand theaters
then by like the second month it'll be
in less than half of those really I
think it'll be a good test for how much
people will spend money on movies in
March because typically like the biggest
movies of the year
don't start coming out till May
May is like the beginning of the
blockbuster season but just a reminder
that Warner Brothers is the one that
moved Batman V Superman because they did
not want to compete with Captain America
Civil War next question Riley asks civil
wars introducing Black Panther and
spider-man to the MCU any possibility of
a Captain Marvel cameo what do you think
about Ronda Rousey is Carole so that's
two different questions first question
Captain Marvel a long time ago when they
were talking about Avengers age of
Ultron
they were gonna include a Captain Marvel
cameo they even shot special-effects
plates for it Joss Whedon said in an
interview that he was like okay we'll
shoot these visual effects plates then
we'll cast the actor and fix it later
so when he was shooting the movie he
assumed that they were going to put
Captain Marvel in the end of the movie
it's that scene at the very end
so like when Scarlet Witch comes down in
her new costume that was meant to be
Captain Marvel but then the last minute
they decided that it was just wait way
too many characters so they're like
we'll wait for Captain Marvel til later
as you know right now Ronda Rousey
really high on the idea of being Captain
Marvel they haven't cast in actors yet I
don't think it's gonna be her I think
they'll go with a safer bet like I like
a proven actress who can open a hundred
fifty million dollar movie all by
herself but as for a cameo in Civil War
I'm actually thinking that the
likelihood is really low I think the
post credits scenes are gonna be
earmarked for setting up Doctor Strange
there'll be a Doctor Strange moment at
the end of Civil War in black panther
maybe thor ragnarok and they really
haven't broke ground on Captain Marvel
on the story yet they hired the writers
but they don't have a director yet and
they don't have an actress so they're
just it's not far long enough if they
had some of those things taken care of I
would say yeah you know better chance
for Captain Marvel cameo but right now
I'm thinking not gonna happen next
question Carrie Dobson s so does
daredevil have a chance of being in this
well a lot of people have said that they
thought they saw him in that blurry cell
phone leaked trailer but that was
actually vision that ant-man was
fighting I don't think that daredevil is
gonna be in Civil War but he might be
mentioned just like a lot of characters
were mentioned at the end of ant-man I'm
not expecting to see any of the Netflix
characters on screen until we see their
defenders team-up and then I think
what'll happen is we'll see the
defenders show up an infinity war as a
team themselves they're kind of trying
to make that Netflix universe its own
thing
for now but that doesn't mean that it's
not connected next question and Ernest s
I still miss the do the thing at the end
of the videos can we just do the thing
at the end of the Marvel videos those
are the ones I watch first and we watch
most often well I would say if more
people had watched Legend of Korra and
knew what do the thing meant like
understood that joke I would totally do
it more
next question Cory asks do you think
that we might see Bucky dawn
red-white-and-blue and Civil War even if
it is just a misdirection by teamcap I
would say if there's anybody that has
any chance of masquerading or even
succeeding Steve Rogers as Captain
America it would be Bucky it's kind of
the other way around in the comics the
Falcon is Captain America or at least he
was before secret Wars
secret Wars is kind of messed everything
up a little bit but there are several
other people in the Marvel Universe that
have worn the Captain America mantle
besides Steve Rogers in the movies
though since we're all like seeing all
this for the first time I would say
Bucky would be the next Captain America
if you have read civil war in the comics
just please use spoiler tags you want to
talk about it because they are doing a
lot of stuff from that storyline I mean
it won't be a carbon copy but it's gonna
be pretty close to comic book Civil War
somatically next question brick blasters
asks just gonna say it again you should
do a Titan Blackbirds video so yeah I've
been getting a lot of questions about
the Teen Titans live-action show they're
doing that's dead it's completely dead
in the water right now there is no video
to be done if you're confused why you
haven't heard about the Teen Titans
live-action show in like a year it's
because they haven't done any work on it
like all the producers that were signed
to that deal or working on other
projects so when people ask them about
this they're like oh yeah we're still
planning on doing that but it's like
it's a long ways off so you probably
won't hear anything about that until
next year it's kind of a bummer but
that's that's the way it goes in
Hollywood like any given producer is
working on like three different shows at
one time next question Morgan asks it's
hard to figure out who will actually be
on the pro registration side Ironman
Warmachine Hawkeye Black Widow
maybe spider-man and black panther well
you actually you kind of named a lot of
the people that are actually on Team
Ironman the only people you left off of
team Ironman is vision he's supposed to
be on Team Ironman black panther isn't
gonna be on anybody's team he's gonna go
back and forth but that's how we get to
like our Black Widow Hawkeye fight Hawk
being team cap along with Scarlet Witch
so I'm really excited to see Scarlet
Witch fight the vision ant-man obviously
is we know you know super fangirl of
Captain America gonna be on Team cap I
think the real surprise is what's going
on with the Hulk like we're not quite
sure what's up with him because
supposedly Mark Ruffalo is in the film
I think there were some cellphone
pictures of him hanging out with the
Avengers cast where they were filming
but we don't actually know what he's
doing in the film he might be the reason
that general Thunderbolt Ross gets
involved
next question monkey bomb squad asks can
anybody recommend any Doctor Strange
stories so because the movie might not
be a straight-up origin story I would
read the oath it's a really modern
retelling of the origin story so it's
it's really great it's really
self-contained I think it's about eight
issues you should be able to find it in
a trade paperback thank you everybody
that submitted questions these are
always a ton of fun to do everybody just
went a little bit nuts like whenever the
footage dropped especially when it
leaked it's really hard to make stuff
out so there was some confusion about
people that did watch the link they're
like who's fighting who I can't see like
it's all blurry
just wait they'll release a nice shiny
version of the trailer in a couple
months and you guys will be able to see
it it'll actually it'll probably
different footage but it'll look way
better anyway I think it was like the
third Avengers trailer before we
actually saw the vision this year so
they might hold spider-man to like the
second or third trailer so don't be
surprised if you don't see him in that
first trailer so what's gonna happen
tomorrow is there's been some new flash
and arrow news for like the new season
so I'm gonna do a video for that stuff
I'm also gonna do my Game of Thrones Q&A
that I normally do I'm just like a day
behind on Game of Thrones stuff so Q&A
tomorrow be sure to subscribe to get
everything if there's any special Marvel
bonus videos that you guys want or any
specific characters you want me to
explain just let me know in the comments
most of the news that we get for the
rest of the year is gonna be specific to
Captain America Civil War because we're
entering like the official marketing
period for the movie when we get within
like six months that's really when they
start to dump stuff so you will be
getting more Civil War than you can
handle along with episode 7 stuff at a
couple months well guys wait for
tomorrow stuff you can click here for my
breakdown to the Civil War footage if
you haven't seen it yet and you can
click here for a breakdown of what's
going on with the Doctor Strange movie
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tomorrow